what does it take to stand out in
overwatch as a tank player like back in
season one i i thought like i was gonna
become 18 and then dominate everybody
basically and that didn't really work
out a game where the meta is constantly
shifting and there's no guarantees that
your favorite hero will be playable at
all
natural selection to survive you need to
be able to stand strong let's keep it
moving
and to win it all
you have to pick your moments
we've got to chase it after marvel and
the whole hog a victory dead for super
liking his way to victory whoever said
lightning doesn't strike twice has never
met the san francisco shock to 2020
overwatch league champions
[Music]
when the game's beta began in 2015
overwatch pulled players from games of
all kinds but there was one game that
had a closer relationship to overwatch
than any other team fortress 2
valve's quirky class-based shooter had
been big in its time but no other
company had succeeded at following that
act
at least not until overwatch all right
play time's over get to cover
and matthew super delesi from
philadelphia pennsylvania was a fitting
representative of this new class of
esports athlete my name is matthew
delisi also known as super i'm 18 and i
play
tank for san francisco shock gaming was
anything but new to him and his
competitive experiences and his initial
teammates were firmly rooted in tf2 well
i played um esea for tf2 and everyone i
played with on bird noises and hammers
and lg they all were tf2 players so we
just uh had a lot of
fps skill while former tf2 players might
have benefited from the game's
similarity to overwatch one role in
particular stood out as drastically
different in the competitive scene the
tank
when your team works on point nothing is
more satisfying in this game than
hitting a big slam it was this new role
that super would ultimately fill but
first he had a couple of obstacles to
overcome when i started playing
overwatch i had like the worst computer
ever like literally 24 fps like the game
is barely running my computer's
overheated actually that's what happened
to my first that's why they get a new
computer because my computer overheated
like the gpu literally fried itself
playing overwatch not to mention he
wasn't even old enough to play
professionally so to be able to play on
land i think is going to be um a big
highlight to have every single match
obviously i can't start day one because
i'm gonna be
too young but when i'm eligible to play
i think it's gonna be
a blast his skill from previous games
and his superior shot calling marked
super as one of the most promising
up-and-coming players in overwatch
oh look at this
holy [ __ ] i'm nuddy
someone stop me with super he is an
excellent read of the game and it's
something that people rally around
everyone agrees with sort of his
leadership when he has something to say
people follow and as esports
organizations signed on for
multi-million dollar contracts to be
part of the forthcoming overwatch league
the san francisco shock signed him
knowing that he wouldn't be able to
start stage one while we're ineligible
to play we're basically going to be
spectating and kind of have like another
anal two analysts coach two people who
understand the game and can provide
input from a third person point of view
things that the players can't see in
game so i think having that is gonna
help but in april 2018 super finally got
his chance to make his debut during
stage three you know it's been a long 20
games of waiting watching my team uh
obviously the reason i came out here was
the play and um i had to wait getting
anxious but finally ready to go out
there and hopefully
you know win some games i think the
biggest thing super will be able to add
is
possibly the finishing of the chaos time
of the san francisco shock when push
comes to shove would they have been in
desperate situations their shock calling
has fallen apart that's what he needs to
get down with this team because that's
been their biggest flaw and while he
initially played more winston he
ultimately became known best for a
different hero
reinhardt
i have been called
where many players saw essentially a
moving wall super found a canvas on
which to paint where some saw boredom
super saw opportunity and as his career
continued he would eventually become
known as the best reinhardt in the
league
but super's debut in the second half of
the 2018 season didn't exactly showcase
his true potential he earned a couple of
mvp nods in some series but the wider
picture was bleak this is such an
important moment for the shock maturity
wise because so often in the first
several stages they seem to grasp defeat
from the jaws of victory they were an
anti-clutch team these found ways to
lose now they found ways to win after
the shock finished ninth during the
inaugural season it was clear some
changes were needed i think it was like
an experience thing kind of maybe a
learning thing as well like back in
season one i thought like i was gonna
become 18 and then dominate everybody
basically and that didn't really work
out um i mean we did all right in the
latter half of the season but it wasn't
you know anything that we expected or
wanted to be going into the off season
the team underwent massive changes
bringing in violet rascal and striker
for super it was an opportunity to carve
out an even bigger spot for himself now
surrounded by talent the pressure was on
super has been almost you can map it
almost in a direct correlation between
how well super has been playing as an
individual and how much more dominant
the shock have been over the course of
2018 into 2019 now the new look shock
managed to eke out a sixth place seed
for the stage one playoffs but once
there they went all the way to the
finals where they lost a heartbreaking
4-3 match to the dominant vancouver
titans before that even with the drastic
roster changes the expectations might
have been middling but now they were
higher than ever and the shock didn't
disappoint in stage two
he has to reveal himself to contest the
payload he does so just for a free
moment but no one else is there
it's over the san francisco shock
completes the golden stage they do not
drop a map they do not drop a series and
i have to say we may never see this
again in the overwatch league it is a
true feat to be sure the shock were for
real not dropping even a single map
during stage two and super's aggressive
and yet calculating reinhardt play was a
big part of the team's success four
minutes on the clock here for the san
francisco shock to pick up the second
point super just gonna throw it out
there's the big shatter two kills if
they can get this done quick shoot
hanging on barely but real you can't say
the same for him and now a golden
opportunity for the shock to get some
real progress on the point this is it
nearing with three and a half minutes on
the clock
follow up there's the shatter wham-bam
thank you ma'am get out
it's gonna be is-37 still on the point
though but that's done into shock
all three
and they didn't stop there they were one
of the league's most dominant teams
reaching the finals of every stage in
2019 but the addition of the roll lock
system to overwatch league for stage
four changed how and when super got to
play the reinhardt he was known for
became scarcer and scarcer due to
orisa's rising popularity and he mostly
sat on the sidelines during the playoffs
as his team's red-hot roster rolled
through the rest of the league until it
was only the vancouver titans standing
between them and the overwatch league
season two finals shocker playing so
aggressively but sinatra already has his
meteor striker though
he can't after much more than that man
making them pay dearly for every
inch of progress but did he walk
straight into that one there was an
amplification matrix an architect made
short work of the main tank slime and
twilight fair
no better than some ensue while he
couldn't even run away from that when he
was frozen still he has to make the same
impact on that hero it's not quite the
same thing blizzard gravity flux
everything he could ask for the shocker
delivering in spades and those
hypospheres are bouncing
and so are the titans craniums the
vancouver titans such a hyped up team
coming from across the ocean cc is down
already though they've lost their main
tank and architect is bringing the
thunder from the back
it's a rain of bullets and the titans
can't do anything about it
only a few seconds left somehow is
removed from the face of the map but
architect is time to get his hands dirty
axel throws a blizzard down but it's not
enough twilight the last hope for the
titans steps up he is filmed cece now
gets to the point but slime is already
removed from the fight the wrecking ball
is down in january he can't touch he is
walled off the
super was on top of the overwatch world
he was a league champion and a key
member of one of the most exciting
rosters the game had ever seen then
invited to represent his country he had
won the overwatch world cup the first
successful international overwatch
campaign in the usa's history he also
represented an important talent that
could be key to the shock's long-term
competitive future but something else
was happening at the same time super was
becoming an incredibly popular
personality both on twitch and in the
rest of the non-overwatch world can i
see the trophy yeah oh it's a little
heavy if you want it to pick it up gosh
this is oh my gosh that's like 40 pounds
it's legit
this is the best trophy i've ever seen
life
super had been streaming since 2017 but
with his name on the rise his stream
really took off in late 2019 and early
2020. he had developed a reputation as a
joker someone who kept the mood light
despite his commitment to performing
in-game
so anyone
oh [ __ ]
i'm so good i'm so good i'm so good i'm
so good at this game where's my shirt
and as it turned out being good at
overwatch was not his only talent boober
looking good tonight super
smart
[Music]
and as his career moved forward he
became the perfect mix of erratic memer
and sardonic flag carrier for a game
that frankly sometimes forced even its
most die-hard supporters to shrug their
shoulders who the [ __ ] plays this game
anyway loads of people
like there's like
me and there's like violet
and
hey good job today even before his team
had secured that 2019 championship an
official league video solidified super
status as the prodigy he is very young
so it almost feels like child prodigy s
but could that prodigal son return to
the top of the overwatch league in 2020
and would the meta allow him to pick up
the hammer again
[Music]
due to the global pandemic all overwatch
league games went online and to make
things worse super's mvp teammate
sinatra left for valorant in april i
think the thing that like held me was
playing for the fans like in front of
people and then the chrono virus made
everything shut down we had to play
online definitely killed it for me but
the main melee showed that even without
their mvp the shock were still the best
team on their half of the newly redrawn
league map do i have any words for soul
not really i kind of just would prefer
to let the play do the talking yeah i
think super was forced to stand up there
if he was halted up there but who knows
anyway he's a rip tire
okay nice super catches that one with
the fire strike that could have been
nasty and now look at the shot push
forward that shatter is good super gets
three fury alarm maybe you and four in
fact try and pick themselves back up but
san francisco they fight off the rip
tyre and then they go up a gear philly
weren't ready for that change of pace
that's big dynamite as well nice shadow
on the side that's everybody on their
back goodbye last row goodbye dreamer
and valiant's hopes and dreams of
winning this map crumbling right before
them the shock threatened a repeat
league victory as they qualified for the
year's grand finals but since half the
teams had essentially been playing in a
league of their own for the year it
wasn't clear how things would shake out
and while reinhardt had been valuable
earlier in the year the bruisery meta
saw super on roadhog a champion that he
made his own even against his grand
finals opponents seoul dynasty
we've got to chase him after marvel and
the whole hog a victory dance for super
liking his way to victory whoever said
lightning doesn't strike twice has never
met the san francisco shock your 2020
overwatch league champions
[Music]
as overwatch 2 was announced sat quiet
and then was delayed the game's future
was uncertain but super stream remained
the funniest safe haven for the game's
faithful even if he wasn't always
playing overwatch
oh my grab him
[Music]
you [ __ ] again
oh my god why did violet say may i sleep
with you and why did you change his
profile picture to me
[Music]
okay well
and despite venturing into other games
super was still known as the overwatch
guy on twitch i got you
oh
pepe
pepper
will you stomp ball i will snap you you
know that he might not have always kept
it as clean as he had to on an overwatch
league stage you stupid little
okay someone just closed the door on me
stop oh wait someone explained before
that's when you like pull your penis
back and like hide it behind your legs
right wait that's when you hide your
penis behind your thighs right
wait what no i didn't do that but in a
world where so many were stuck inside
super's weird brand of humor seemed to
hit perfectly but on the overwatch
league stage 2021 was a different
challenge for super the shock lost aunts
rascal and moth they still had their
deep front line from 2020 but confidence
in them dropped still as reinforced
pointed out on plat chat of the teams
with a 1-1 record at that time the shock
did have some serious upside heading
into the countdown cup in june 2021. i'm
probably looking out for shock here
actually because their versatility yes
their initial match was a bit messy
against the dallas fuel
but overall it's proven now that they
can play a lot of different compositions
nero can play the pharah they can play
the rhino composition uh they can play
the wrecking ball as well to an extent
and i like this versatility from them at
the end of the 2021 season their record
was good enough to earn them a shot at
play-ins meeting only to beat the
toronto defiant to move on
he's also fallen on the fire that was
like damn it it was an aggressive risky
play and it's blown up in their face
this has just been a really tough
matchup for toronto uh
like clearly they are a better team uh
than what we've seen today but
do not have the power to beat a team
like san francisco as
the shock are back in the playoffs a 3-0
sweep here of the defiant but
unfortunately things didn't go as
planned during the playoffs the shock
finished fourth after a heartbreaking
loss to the atlanta reign
after re-signing with the shock it's not
clear exactly where the future will take
super as his stream has grown and he's
made another appearance on jimmy fallon
it wouldn't be hard to see his
personality breaking free of the
overwatch league particularly as the
sequel's fate remains uncertain and
while overwatch has seen big players
leave for other games losing super would
be different because whether it's on
stage or on stream overwatch just
wouldn't be the same without him
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock